Arcane doesn't put ladders in its games
the team says as much with a succinctly
stated poster in one of the rooms in its
Austin location
flatters it reads the team has said
ladders feel limiting by putting players
in a mode where they can't use their
weapons or abilities and they often even
fall to their deaths anyway Arcane hates
ladders and yet there are ladders early
and often in redfor this surprise would
become emblematic of my time in the
vampire infested Massachusetts town
redfall is Arcane making compromises to
its own design philosophies to serve a
genre it may have been better off
avoiding
go away
redfull is a full player co-op looter
shooter that pits players against
vampires and the cultists who follow
them the story premise is classic Arcane
stuff but in practice it plays like a
tug of war that it's usually inventive
team could not win most aspects of what
the team is known for unrivaled World
design intricate immersive Sim elements
improvisational combat are rarely found
here in their place are run and
gunfights with unresponsive AI enemies
amid a host of bugs that are so
prevalent it genuinely feels dejecting
to see the game launch in this state
wherever things have gone wrong in
redfall and there are several places it
feels like the result of a team with a
foot in disjointed worlds what it's
known for and what it's tasked with
doing the game's two maps are bigger
than anything Arcane has done before
from either its team in Texas or friends
but the team struggles to fill that
space with the same intricacies that
made games like Dishonored and death
Loop both Game of the Year winners and
prey occult classic too often you and up
to three others playing in Co-op will
move across Barren beaches or through
wooded areas with little more than some
sheds or campsites to rummage through
the game's second map which you'll
unlock halfway through the campaign is
noticeably better because it comes
closer to the team's past efforts with
more interesting landmarks and more
verticality built into its neighborhoods
but it still doesn't quite get there
traveling from A to B in creative ways
has always been arcane's signature and
in redfall there are opportunities to
get crafty when entering some buildings
like by going through the roof by
picking a lock on a door or by climbing
through a window but moments like these
are two spread apart and in the middle
will often find blander elements such as
small gangs of enemies waiting to be
dispatched with no more consideration
than choosing which gun to use in
redfall you can only really speak one
language killing enemies there's no
reward for creatively completing
missions and you're eventually funneled
into an all-out firefight in every
encounter even when you take the time to
play smarter discouraging you from
trying to solve any problem in a more
creative way than just shooting everyone
enemies in redfull are unresponsive to a
degree that I would never expect from a
team as talented as this and from a
publisher as resource rich as Bethesda
picking off enemies with a sniper will
often result in nearby enemies carrying
on with their day unfazed by their
allies dying off in combat they will
often take too long to shoot and
struggle to take cover letting you get
in killing blows for they've hardly
reacted in any way at all even the
vampires who are meant to serve as
bigger tougher enemies sometimes use
attacks that are so easily counted it
renders them afterthoughts in many cases
like a lunge that you can just back up
to avoid
the stealth mechanics are also
underdeveloped sneaking up behind an
enemy to deliver a knockout blow has no
animation of its own you just whack them
in the same way you shatter a window and
this method unpredictably leads to some
enemies being defeated While others
survive the blow and kick off normal
combat under bosses serve as
neighborhood terrorizers whom you must
draw out after completing local missions
but in virtually every case they can be
one or two-shotted on normal difficulty
with the game's stake launcher a weapon
that is too powerful for the game's own
good Stakes should kill vampires quickly
of course but because they do the
ubiquity of stake launchers nullifies
many of the game's Encounters this is a
balancing issue that is common in
redfall even the game's intended tougher
Parts like vampire nests and overpowered
enemies called Rooks who spawn every so
often when you've caused too much Mayhem
can be overcome pretty breezily in most
cases and when that wasn't the case
often the opposite was true suddenly
overwhelming enemy forces would result
in instant death the game rarely strikes
the right balance
a little bit
redfull is the latest in a long line of
games to develop an obsession with loot
but the game struggles to nail even the
basic well-established concept of how
that loot should be dolled out in most
other loot heavy games tiered loot drops
on a reliable upward trajectory early
loot grants you common or slightly
uncommon weapons and as you progress
you'll see the loot getting gradually
better and rarer in redfall the weapons
tend to get stronger but their Rarities
follow no pattern the five color-coded
Rarities can each drop at any point in
the campaign I was Finding purples and
golds in the first hour just as I was
Finding Grays and greens in the final
few missions as such the loot aspect of
redfall feels faulty and unnecessary in
one perplexing moment during one of the
first side missions a Loot drop
simultaneously granted me a gray sniper
a green sniper a blue sniper and a
purple sniper there are some cool guns
to be found like a UV beam that turns
vampires to Stone so you can then blast
them the Pebbles but the best guns are
notable for their basic functions not
because of RNG defined perks that have
been ham-fisted into yet another game
it's easy to see a version of redfall
that has smaller but deeper maps without
the loot system perhaps that would be
too much like the team's other games
which makes redfall stand out for being
different in arcane's catalog but in all
the ways it's different it's worse its
story which is actually full of
interesting lore similarly struggles to
leave its mark because of the genre's
all too common use of stiff Quest givers
dishing out instructions as they stand
in the same place for the whole game
arcane's worlds have always been rich
with character and environmental
storytelling but redfull needs to serve
its looter shooter master so cardboard
like NPC's feign narrative Intrigue
leaving the plot to feel like window
dressing because we all lost someone out
there though thanks for trying what
could have been a fun story that
basically equates Venture capitalists to
bloodsuckers is instead nullified by
forgettable delivery at nearly every
turn while alkane's abandonment of its
own Core Design principles is jarring
from a fan point of view you need not
have played anything from the team
before to be stunned by redfull's lack
of Polish this game is simply not ready
and yet here it is meant to serve as the
Spring Showcase for Xbox game pass
there's really no flavor of bug or
glitch I did not encounter game crashes
a t pose and characters oddly
duplicating character models
disappearing Quest items incorrect UI
information texture popping and of
course the game's lack of a 60 frames
per second mode which was recently a
pre-launch headline too redfall sorely
misses a higher frame rate but I saw
moments during intensive combat where it
strugged to even maintain 30 frames prey
is 6G years old and looks better than
redfall the lack of arcane's usual Flair
is disheartening the presence of so many
bugs is just insulting this game is for
sale but it shouldn't be
the Silver Lining is faint but Dreadful
does have a few things going for it for
one it's foursome a vampire sling heroes
are all fun to inhabit not just because
of their unique abilities but their
personalities too the more you complete
missions with a particular group of
Co-op Partners the more your characters
will communicate as they build trust
this helps color in their identities
which can be difficult in a game and
genre that is so often focused on
filling space and time with things to do
to the point of drowning out its Heroes
they also play off each other well due
to their unique skills it feels like the
studio took its usual protagonist
concept and divided it into quarters
this can sometimes mean solo players
feel like they're incomplete existing is
only a fraction of Praise Morgan new or
dishonored's corvo or Emily but when
played in Co-op team Synergy shines
using one Hero's ability to teleport
over a gap where then another lifts up
the team using her elevator-like
maneuver to get onto a roof so that a
third team mate can drop in through the
Skylight and cloak past enemies to
unlock the front door and let them all
in to cause chaos is the sort of
player-driven moment that I thought this
game would have a lot of it doesn't have
them often enough but when they occur
the game is at its best while the world
doesn't feel like the player's canvas in
ways you might expect it is nonetheless
a fun place to explore in one very
particular way it leans into its
Massachusetts setting in a manner that
suggests to me a native of the state
that someone on the team really likes it
there moving down Cobblestone Pathways
lined with pumpkins to collect junk loot
like legally distinct chain store donuts
and candles that smell of steamed
lobster all while NPCs with thick Boston
accents berate each other over the
airwaves like they're talking about the
socks was an authentic Touch of Home
though I understand few players will get
the same enjoyment out of that aspect
ultimately redfall is a game that should
not have been released yet it's Litany
of bugs hampers the gameplay Loop of
exploring its world with friends and
that Loop itself feels compromised by
elements that are poorly executed and
ill-suited to the team implementing them
I can't pretend to know whether Arcane
chose to make a looter shooter or was
assigned to make a looter shooter but I
can't tell you what it feels like one of
the best game studios in the world
suddenly made Toothless
what's up